thank you thank you they organizer for
the invitation and so of course there is
some overlap with the previous talk so i
will probably just flesh out some slide
that i put there just in case unlikely
case that some people you know show up
yeah exactly okay so so i will skip
those okay so maybe just just notation
so for a rectangle with side m and n so
omega and then we'll sorry yeah this
will be the set of all possible
triangulation the reason in an important
case maybe just to keep in mind is what
happens when when one one side of the
original rectangle is one so this is an
extremely thin rectangle so in this case
there is a one-to-one correspondence
between lat e strangulation and lattice
path this will start to be a useful
guide line to understand certain mixing
time result later on so in particularly
the the corresponding is for example if
if a triangular if a triangle as a
horizontal side up then you pew put
Union in the in the lattice path you put
a 45 unit segment up and so for example
here we have 12 want to up then one down
up up again etc okay so so this is a is
a it's a corresponding between these two
object and so when we will run some some
global dynamics on the triangulation in
this very specific case this will
transfer in the usual mountain valley
dynamics for lattice back yes sorry no
that's what we will discuss today what
what happens today saying this trip is
more complicated thing triangles are
actually in will be just triangle in
which M so the so I will always take the
regional side very long so an arbitrary
long and the vertical side m which is
finite okay maybe actually we could even
take you know very very slowly growing
but let's let's say constant okay so
Alex already outlined this difference
but I want to do it again because this
will explain certain complication that
we have one study in the mixing time of
the global dynamics with respect to spin
model so each each edge of the lattice
regulation as a mid point and this point
is is is fixed is deterministic okay so
if you are one when you sign an edge to
a midpoint is like assigning a spin okay
first of all the spin can have many many
values okay not just like say easing
spin with two values and so for spin
system that the most important point is
that for spin system on a graphs
interaction is local once you once you
fix the neighbor of a waypoint then the
law of the spin in that point is given
is the sign however an edge I mean as in
a spin system on on on a graph if so if
the interaction is local so so the law
of the of the spin at the vertex once
you specify the value of the spin around
and the law at that vertex is specified
typical is a very simple okay so it is
through that an edge as always for
neighboring edges just the on the two
triangles on which the edge belong
however the corresponding midpoints of
these four neighboring edges they can be
arbitrarily far from the midpoint of the
adyar you are looking at and therefore
dizzy there is a strong lack of locality
or geometry if you want okay and this
causes most of the update difficulties
in the Indian alice's of the global
dynamics okay so okay again so energy
flippable it belongs to do is if it is
the diagonal of a parallelogram this is
an example and as Alex said I mean the
flip graph is always connected okay so
okay so if you want to sample from the
uniform distribution you can run the
dynamics in which you you choose an edge
and if the edges flippable you flip it
with equal probability and instead if we
if you want to sample from the get
distribution that you described then you
have to do with the Europe you have to
flip the edge with with different rate
in such a way that is reversible okay so
we saw the beautiful simulations or the
simulation suggests that there is a
phase transition for lambda 1 and and
the precise conjecture for the behavior
of the mixing time is the following so
there should be fast mixing for for any
lambda less than 1 there should be an
exponential torpid mixing for any lambda
bigger than one and we conjecture but we
really don't know if it is for lambda
equal one is polynomial it's some
polynomial in that case would be
interesting first to determine that the
polynomial and then maybe looking for
them for in the power for the exact
exponent now let's see what what what
what is known now so here we'll describe
some result that
advance of this length side of the of
the rectangles okay so the first result
is rapid mixing for some small lambda so
if lambda is sufficiently small smaller
than 1 then with any possible of
constraint edges that are for example
boundary boundary edges that are
sticking in your ear rectangular data
frozen then they meet the mixing time is
what it should be is what is conjectured
to be and instead if if lambda is bigger
than 1 then we have an exponential
result but still favre is so is still
not not open now in the sense that so we
can prove that the mixing time for any
lambda bigger than one else i'll show
you how is exponentially large in the
say the longest side of the rectangle
while in fact I mean we were expecting
say 4x squared like exponentially 9 cube
so we are really we are really still far
from there from the optimal result okay
so maybe just just few words how how we
prove this this distro result so so for
rapid mixing for small lambda we use pad
coupling plus the exponential metric and
this was inspired by peppered by green
bear pascoe and Dana in online that so
this exponential is is now is sort of
well-known technique in a sense it's
established technique so the exponential
matrix is divided that we want to
contract under the pad coupling is so if
you take two configuration that
difference only at one of our for the
Academy
metrics were used in the paper that you
know by muscle and clear Kenyan and
myself for red yeah I apologize mm-hmm
okay so if we have to track a 23
angulations the different only for an
edge that midpoint X then then the
distance and we fix the distance like
that okay so if they different just in a
trivial way namely the two edges at the
midpoint are just one unit diagonal and
the opposite unit diagonal off of a unit
square then is this value otherwise
otherwise is this is this quantity here
and alpha is is some number bigger than
one and then the main result is that if
lambda is small enough one hit that's
come from all the pyres argument that
and now result that Alex described in
the previous talk then actually we can
prove that this on why so contracts in
the pad coupling sense so after one step
of the dynamics there is a contraction
okay and from there using the fact that
the matrix exponential you recover
immediately the result that I that I
mentioned before for rapid mixing so
totally mix instead for lambda bigger
than one well the approach is the
standard one so you look for a
bottleneck in the phase space in the
space of configuration and so so so an
exponential bottleneck is a set in the
outcome of triangulation such that the
ratio of the probabilities between the
boundary of the set and the set itself
is say X Pinelli small okay and so the
bounder here are the triangulation in
the set such that with just one flip of
the of the triangulation you get out of
the set okay so this is a standard tool
that once you have an exponential
bottleneck then the mixing time is
essentially the inverse of this of this
ratio okay so here is the
so here is an exponential battlenet
notice that is very different from what
we saw in the in the simulation so in
the simulation we saw that the typical
configuration for lambda bigger than one
they're mostly one orientation okay and
so a very natural bottleneck would be
something like all three angles of the
triangulation that have say ninety nine
percent of the edges there dis dis
orientation and then the boundary would
be triangulation that in a sense you
know with one flip you get out of this
set and so they should have start up too
many edges that I have you know an
orientation that is wrong okay this we
try for a while but we we didn't succeed
what we succeed in finding is this what
we call the herringbone bottleneck so in
each one dimensional layer for the for
the rectangle you put edges with with
say positive negative orientation like
in this like in this pattern like the
you know the codes for the you know
men's code okay and and so here I mean
so this is really an exponential
bottleneck because if you if you take a
triangulation that is that has this
shape but as is at the boundary namely
with just one flip you can you can get
out of the set then this mean that this
dysregulation as a vertical unit
vertical edge in one of the layers okay
and just by turning this this edge you
get out of this herringbone pattern and
then you can so using this observation
you can compute the the cost that the
probabilistic costs for for having a an
edge that is vertical somewhere so if
the edge actually is vertical and is
sort of in the middle of overlay here
then the cost would be exponential in n
square negative exponential in square
but actually
this vertical guy could be also like at
the beginning then the cost is only n
okay and and this gives gives them gives
the result that that was mentioned here
okay so actually it is a it is an open
problem either even to understand what
is exactly the shape of the ground state
namely ground state you know the the the
triangulation with the longest possible
length okay so say is an interesting
problem that is open
yeah we have an improvement for
reporting rectangles later inshallah
i'll show that okay so thin thin
rectangles namely rectangle in which the
vertical side is constant compared to
the to the very long horizontal side the
shorter should be should they should
behave similarly to the one-dimensional
case ok so the one-dimensional case
correspond to this lattice path and the
dynamics there is well understood and
this is and this is the situation so if
m is one so if lambda is less than 1
then the mixing time gives a really like
n square if lambda is bigger than one
and is exponential in n square and if
lambda is exactly one this was you you
can solve it by various method but say
you can use the coupling method by by
Wilson which is very precise apart a
constant factor and then the mixing time
is n cubed log in okay so okay so what
what are the result for thin rectangle
so when M now is not one but constant
okay so unfortunately there is no longer
a representation like with using lattice
pad okay so situation is really gets
much more involved and the result is the
following is that so for lambda less
than one mixing time is like an square
exactly as it should be for lambda
bigger than one is again exponential in
n square but the exponential rate
deteriorates when M increases okay and
however we we don't know anything about
the case even even for thin rectangles
we don't know about the case lambda 1
okay so okay so at the certain high
level description of how to prove this
this result so the so here we use a
again the bottleneck approach okay
however here that we can we can improve
and get the exponential of n square okay
accepting a deteriorating rate of 1 over
m okay and and so this is how this is
improving the herringbone picture namely
instead of asking of having a complete
herringbone in each one dimensional
layer we only ask the herring bone
structure in say ninety percent of the
layer away from from the boundaries okay
and so that actually allows us to to to
get that the energy cost is n square and
allows that to do it aight aight
comparison of the partition functions of
the some of the of the weight for each
configuration when we take the ratio of
the probabilities but this is all sorry
this is only possible when when m is is
order one also is finite ok so otherwise
we get this this bad factor here so
instead I mean what what about the the n
square mixing time so the lower bound is
simple because it's just them it's like
the diameter of the of the space and so
what is interesting is there is the
upper band so there the the route 22 to
prove it is rather elaborate so first we
prove that in time and square starting
from any arbitrary triangulation we
enter a good set of triangulation we're
good set of triangulation means say
order log in length for each edges and
four and for this result we use in a
it it is a key consequence of the
Lyapunov function that Alex described
okay because outside I mean I mean when
when when when you have edges that are
longer than log n then the Lyapunov
function of height function that the
described has a contraction properties
of decreases and this able so enables to
prove that there is like a drift
condition and you are you enter in n
square step you enter this this this
good set and actually you can prove that
once you enter their use you stay for as
a a large polynomial in n time like n to
the 10 okay we are shooting for n square
so that's more than enough before I mean
we can only concentrate on a restricted
chain inside this do this good set okay
and okay so there we there now this this
analogy with spin system which in
principle is extremely dangerous because
midpoints of two neighboring edges they
can be geometrically very far apart
given the fact that the edges are not
too too long maybe now this can be sort
of restored at least partially restore
and this is exactly what is going to
happen so we we will use lok sabha level
so we have to do to prove Lok Sabha left
bound plus improve canonical Pat
argument and i'm going to describe
shortly this this this part here okay so
maybe i'll give just the the main tools
that can be derived from there from the
Lyapunov function of Alexander okay so
so yeah lambda equals 1 is M equals 2
already trusting orders yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah okay so there is a
first result that says that the
probability that at any time larger than
n say constant and square the
probability that you see an edge that is
longer than L this as an exponential
tale ok and then so the second lemma
actually also saw in presence of
arbitrary constraint edges and that is
important because when we will want when
we will study the Lok Sabha love
constant for this system typically
boundary condition enters and one has to
take sort of the worst possible
situation and therefore we need the
tools that hold also in presence of
fixed edges that we call constraint
edges ok ok so this maybe we can really
skip this but yeah because it will be
used later on so a key point is that
that is more easy to grasp is the
following so suppose that you have your
rectangle and you cut off a say a
central part of the rectangle that you
call our and suppose that you have
constrained edges ok now suppose that
you have say two boundary condition for
the triangulation here namely constraint
edges that are different that are tau or
constraint edges that are completely in
a different situation now Prime but you
assume that both tau and tau prime are
not intersecting the dis dis our region
that you are looking at then the results
as the following that so you will you
will have to to you know gives measure
corresponding to these fixed edges or
other freaks edges other version of The
Fixer jeez muta prime and then for
lambda less than one with the a
probability exponentially close to one
in this in this length here you find
four yup you can couple this to
measuring this this amazing in such a
way that they have a common vertical
crossing of unit vertical edges okay
that is actually is a key tool because
imagine that for example the that the
constraint edges are only on one side
say on the right-hand side and you want
to prove that the to measure on the
left-hand side they look the same okay
then one way to say is that okay at some
point that we love a you know a common
vertical crossing okay and then after
that you can just make an exact coupling
okay so this is a this is the essence of
of this result okay so this will so this
this lemma will allow us to to to
implement this rough idea okay so back
to to to to death in triangles okay so
so the first step is a burning phase
okay that last n square actually takes
most of the time okay so you start from
any configuration then using the misdo
stool from the Lyapunov function you
enter a good set and you stay there for
a large amount of time say n to the 10
okay now given this the this structural
property of the triangulation the the
original unconditional measure and the
measure and the gives measure condition
to stay in this good set they are there
they're very very very small variation
distance so it is actually enough to
prove that the restricted chain mixes
inside the set in a time that say is
little o of n square so much smaller
compared to day to the burning time okay
okay so step two of course at some point
we have to prove some special mixing
call it strong
special mixing maybe okay so the
situation is definitely you should you
should only concentrate so forget about
this v-0 v1 v2 v3 just look at before
and we have this left and right
rectangle so imagine that you have your
rectangle here okay and and you fix say
a configuration of edges here you fix
maybe another edge configuration in this
indecision in this end in the same
rectangle here that is not drawn okay
and you want to and you want to compare
the two marginals of the corresponding
measure on the left rectangle okay well
because of the of this result on the
high probability of having a vertical
crossing actually what you what you can
prove is that the two marginal given
this boundary con this this edge
configuration here or here the two
marginal on the left they are very very
close actually they are very close in a
very strong sense i mean the relative
density is very close to one actually is
exponentially in this distance close to
one okay so that's a key input to attack
than the this log but logarithm is a
brief constant look yeah for example
yeah morally local grain but yeah just
to be safe we will some poly log okay so
how to prove the logarithmic sobolev
constant for the four for the restricted
chain ok so the at high level we use
this helping procedure that has been
used also for spin system many many
different setting ok so you so in a
sense you want to go from scale and to
scale n over 2 then n over 4 etc up to a
scale that is like poly log and there
you stop and try
do maybe something else okay that's the
that's the pattern of the proof so so
there's the standard way that standard
method is definitely you take care the
initial scale and you divide this in
approximately two rectangles of length n
over 2 and but they have a little
overlap say poly log okay or say log
even even large constant log okay so so
lambda 1 is to the left lambda to the
right now the spatial mixing property
implies that if you compute the entropy
the entropy of any function non negative
function the entropy approximately facto
Rises and this is a is the null result
by chassis and actually so so factorize
like that that so is its like the
average of the entropy here plus the
average of the entropy in this other
rectangle okay there is a very small
correction factor so once you have a
quasi factorization of the entropy if
you look for example at the entropy of
lambda 1 this is on a on a scale that is
roughly n over 2 okay so that
immediately suggests that there is a
multi scale analysis okay okay so very
quickly so this is the Dirac reform this
is the transition matrix for the chain
that's the entropy and the logarithmic
sobolev concern is this supremum and
stand the result that the mixing time so
I put a tilde just to say that this is
for the restricted chain in the good set
is so is the logarithm is a brief
constant time a correction that is long
so if you prove that this logarithm is a
brave constant is and to a power less
than 2 then certainly your them which is
so actually the result is this one and
therefore the mixing time in the good
set is occurs on a scale that is much
shorter than n square ok
okay so once you almost factorize the
end of the entropy then immediately you
get that the logarithmic sub olive
constant on scale okay say originals
case hit twice n is up sorry there is
that the two here is is run so this the
logarithmic sorry scaly on the initial
scale n is the suburb constant on scale
half then there is this this correction
of the factorization of the entropy then
there is this nasty too now this nasty
factor of two comes from the fact that
there is an overlap and all the flip of
the edges in the overlap are counted
both in the left rectangle and indirect
angles are counted so there is an over
counting problem ok so this of course is
not acceptable this and this over
counting because if you if you iterate a
logarithmic number of time to to to to
to this logarithmic becomes a power ok
but you do ok this a trick of a like a
random averaging of where to choose the
overlap of the rectangle and then this
random averaging sorry reduces this to
to another factor that is well well
behaving now just were new the following
that so here i am using really sloppy
notation because whenever i consider say
that entropy in this rectangle here and
imagine that all the edges here are
fixed so they behave like boundary
condition so i should write boundary
condition on top of all this constant
which would result in a complete mess
for the notation so but so is this is
important anyway if you if you use these
multi scale analysis you go down up to
two a poly log scale and then you stop
ok
so now we have to do something else okay
so a first bound would be to prove a
bound that is typical in spurts pin
system is like a trivial bound is an
exponential bound okay so actually this
is not difficult but it's not sufficient
because the exponential of a poly log is
is too bad for us there is another
obstacle is that once we start
conditioning on in scale when we get
down on scale on the final scale poly
log there are many constrained edges
sticking in that comes from the highest
scale through all the scale through all
the intermediate scale okay and this and
this and these edges they are of length
at most log n but they could be actually
log n now login on scale poly log is
like a small power okay so on this scale
and on the on the final scale we
actually have to imagine that we have
boundary edges that are coming they are
on length that is a small power of the
scale we are considering therefore
straightforward bootstrapping which so
naive bootstrapping which would be you
know we did this this this multi scale
analysis we go from n to poly log then
we proved an exponential trivial bound
exponential in a poly log now we go back
okay and we say oh actually now we know
that for a scale is only exponential of
a poly log of that scale go back here
okay and then you get exponential of
actually a poly log of a poly log and
then your and then you would be done
okay however that is not possible
because in all this constant we should
put a little label n because all the
maximal length of the edges is log n is
not reducing once you go down on scale
okay so so this is a this is not is an
obstacle okay so really we need
something else so we need some another
tool okay so we need for example a poly
it's a polynomial bound on the Lok Sabha
life on this scale by some different
means okay so at first that a first time
would be to to say okay the Lok Sabha
live is bounded by polynomial x there in
verse relaxation it by the relaxation
time in the spectral gap so the
relaxation time you estimate with the
congestion rate using a canonical path
however unfortunately typically the
canonical path they give you an
exponential congestion rate and so we
are back to start okay here is an
improver canonical argument so this
actually I mean they'd this improved
canonical part that i'm using actually
was used i guess for the first time with
the a yell alan petrol and Fabio Tony
Nellie some dynamics for random surfaces
a completely different context but a
suspect that should be somewhere also in
the literature but okay anyway so
suppose that you have the general
settings are reversible Markov chain and
suppose that you have a subset of the
state space such that for any pair of
the state in this subset like the good
subset is possible to define a canonical
path which is entirely in the in the in
the subset k prime and call the kanji
the congestion rate for for this path c
KY prime fixed time t and suppose that
rosie is a lower bound for the
probability starting from any starting
point that at time T you are in the good
set then the relaxation time of the full
chain is is bounded by this this
expression so roughly T squared over row
and then the congestion in the good set
divided by Rho square ok so there is a
trade-off not by in choosing t-raww etc
ok
he is the burning time to get to the set
yeah sarta get there stay there no no no
no no no no yeah yeah this is an RO is
that the minimum probability to be at
that time in the good set okay actually
is is is not really difficult to prove
this this this result so back now so now
we would like to apply this improve
canonical but argument to two thin
rectangles okay so the so the result is
the following so consider the original
let me say the result for the original
triangulation so they also consider the
Regent regulation and suppose that
boundary there are boundary edges that
could stick in O'Kane they are even very
long but say no more than say n over 4
okay then the relaxation time is
actually polynomial in n not maybe the
right power not one or two but say a
polynomial and then we will and then the
corollary of this theorem Kersey once
you apply this theorem to the to the
scale poly log your you're done okay so
once they relaxation time and poly logs
is polynomial of the poly log so is a
poly log then also the Lok Sabha visas
poly log in and the proof is finished
okay so this is a sketch of course so we
want to apply this this improve
canonical so we want to find a good set
of where is possible to define canonical
pass with the only polynomial congestion
rate and not exponential okay so Omega
prime is as following so remember that
we may have you know edges thickening
which forces the minimal ends of certain
edges to be even very long like fraction
of n even okay and so the good set is
like that that any edge does not exceed
by more than log the minimal it's
ground state so the it's minimal allowed
length okay and they similar and then
there is a similar property so if any
edge cross is the ground state at
another point then the length of this
edge is essentially dictated by the
ground state at the point X with the
with a buffer of log in ok
I did it I so does not exceed the area
ok ok so the lemma is the following now
that if you take T sorties this time to
enter the good set ok so which is ok
constant m and square then Omega Prime
satisfy the hypothesis of the of the
canonical path with the burning lemma ok
with also the minimum probability this
is bigger equal than one-half again this
was one of the tool that i described
coming from this Lyapunov function ok
and actually it is possible to construct
path inside the set with a polynomial
congestion rate ok so that's maybe so
the last last bit just so the
construction of the patty I mean it's
not really completely straightforward
certainly this is not the place to do
that but maybe just the sort of the
basic principle is the following so
given to add 12 to confute Oh
triangulation we have to construct a
path going from sigma 2 eita now in
principle so if you want to say
transform the edge at X say access my
watch ok in Sigma to the corresponding
edges edge in ETA maybe you have you are
I mean in order to do that you have to
adjust many many other edges it would
maybe mid point that is very very far
away from X in principle ok that's one
of the main feature of this
triangulation problem ok now the fact
that we are in this set Omega prime
means that this how far you have to
correct stuff in order to be able to
bring the edge Sigma X to the edge of
attacks is not essentially more than
order log n ok so then this suggests
that if you take the original rectangle
and
you divided into slabs of length order
log n then you can sort of process
construct a path going from sigma theta
starting from the left so adjusting all
day all the edges here and in doing that
maybe you have to correct the edges also
in the second slab man no more then you
go to the second slab maybe you have to
correct also a little bit of the turtle
let's lab and you proceed like that okay
exactly as you would do for us a
one-dimensional spin model okay left to
right okay and then of course you have
to check that the congestion rate that
you get is only is only polynomial okay
so that's an the proof thank you
further sub correctly so how do you get
this trucks possibility sorry get these
jobs faster weeks oh now the special
mixing some may be the main result is
this one I'll show you again is this ok
so imagine that you have a rectangle on
the board yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
rough sketches the phone so you have a
rectangle and you examine a central part
here okay ok so suppose that you put a
boundary condition or your you condition
on what you see here ok but none of
these edges they they touch this guy ok
and suppose that you consider another
version of the same problem ok and here
there are some different edge different
edges ok what you can prove is the
following using the technique of alex is
that this so that is the coupling of
these two distribution such that with
high probability in this intermedia in
this central rectangle they share a
vertical vertical crossing of of edges
once they share a common vertical
crossing then you can couple to the left
with with identity completely that's
them yeah
typically in SA I don't know say spin
system a property that that is enforced
but using like pyres so very so you need
some extreme value of the parameter okay
so so is remarkable that here thanks to
this Lyapunov function is possible to
get that up to excluded of course lambda
1 yeah that's number